donaldson sliding into the d.h spot that
was previously held in the original
starting lineup by nelson cruz starting
pitcher
kenta maeda making his 15th start of the
season
see his stats his last three games 25
strikeout versus four walks here's
shohei ohtani
and a strikeout maeda wins the first
round
between himself and the countryman
one down that'll bring up upton
a good pitch sequence from
kentucky
he got him a swing at that
second strike for a good change up
and put that thought in the back of
ohtani's
mind and snuck the fastball right past
him so one down fletcher aboard and now
justin upton's
could be two
one
double play as maeda works a scoreless
first inning after one half at target
field angels nothing twins are coming up
dandruhini tonight on the mount for the
angels 30 year old veteran left-hander
and looking to improve his record to six
and seven tonight jorge polanco coming
off great series against the chicago
white sox six for 12 with the two homers
a ball in two strikes from heeney made
him chase and a strikeout for andrew to
start his night one out one on for
donaldson
and a couple of strikeouts for andrew
heaney as he fans donaldson with a man
on you'll notice the difference here
that wrist the way he got on top of that
instead of going down and away it cut in
and it got him
two on two out in the bottom half of the
first and jeffers
fastball up and it does the job three
strikeouts in the first is heeney
strands a pair scoreless in minnesota
one out no score there's max stassi
catcher
cenote of the bag polanco with a great
play at second base
not hit hard at all but man did he ever
have to cover a lot of ground to get
there great athleticism right there from
polanco he said he had to cover a lot of
ground and the ball looked like he had
some funky english so it was when it hit
the ground it
was kicked back right
he was able to make an off throw
athletic throw to first base
see the funky spin on that ball good
hips he was able to open up and make a
strike to cenote to get the out larnica
board with one gun so here's celestino
but that's lined into the corner and
that's trouble
larnick scooting around third they're
gonna try to send him home
here's the relay to the plate and it's
in time to get him
now he called him out he's hurt
i think he missed the plate and he
dropped the ball and then he was able to
come back and apply the tag it looked
like
that was a great relay i don't think
larnick ever got to the plate we'll take
a look at it again stassi did drop the
ball
i'll tell you i was surprised that they
sent him
good hustle by up then getting quickly
into your cutoff man that's what you
want to do
in a quick throw
to the plate the tag is on there
you see he never got to the plate
larnick and then he drops the ball
though i wonder if he didn't have that
that play is made i thought he might
play it up right
well i i don't not understand the call
at all
he's out right here
he's out
and the ball doesn't pop out until the
play is over
but then fortunately enough he had he
responded back and still applied attack
before lara can even get to the plate
here's austin deal first and third one
out
slice down the line fair into the corner
ceno will score easily larnick around
third they're going to hold him this
time with ostidio driving in the game's
first run it's usual for ostedio
to swing at the first pitch
but other than the larnica walk every
batter has gone up there and taking a
hack at the first pitch of this inning
you got a fastball down the middle and
you know oscar was always in swing mode
and you know during batting practice
today i was challenging him to hit the
ball to right field so i'm sure he's
going to have a lot to say about that
double so ostino doubled his first time
up two runners in scoring position the
angels playing their infield back
tapper to third
heading home will arnick will score
celestino getting his first run batted
in
on something other than a home run good
great by larnick
charging home on the slow chopper you
see
learning and third vapes was going on
contact but you can see as he started to
veer out to give the catcher
you know give the third baseman a
throwing room and you know that's not
something you should do right there you
keep on your straight line make him make
the adjustment you don't make the
adjustment two nothing twins twins got
their two runs last inning in the bottom
of the fourth angels batting top of the
fifth down two nothing runners at second
and third one out
[Music]
came inside and got too much of the
plate mayfield hits it to left and gone
captain jack with a three-run shot
that is that back-up slider
that has
been an issue for maida this year that's
his seventh home run
on a mistake slider he was looking and
tracking slider and he got a lot more of
the plate and he didn't miss it
jack
mayfield going yard three run home run
the three run shot this that back up
spinning breaker ball that stays right
out over the plate he stayed down on
that one didn't try to pull he just had
that good part of the bat and lines it
out what a swing by mayfield
captain jack will hit it high tonight
andrew heaney working with a 3-2 lead
bottom of the sixth inning ceno jeffers
and larnak stepping up 2-2 pitch to suno
got him on the high gas
strikeout number five for end rouhini
i was getting ready to say he's due to
strike out man he's only not struck out
15 times this year of 72 games giving
him now 800 strikeouts on the season one
gone for ryan jeffers
back to back strikeouts open the sixth
to play now is larnak who has singled
walked and scored a run
there's one that's chased and missed a
high 2-2 fastball thrown past the batter
and larnach strikes out and heaney
strikes out the side in order two down
and now mayfield two and two on
mayfield back for a fastball struck him
out seven good innings for maeda but
still down a run
iglesias on the bump trying to pick up a
save angel starters on the road this
month have really been good and heaney
continuing that tonight
that'll do it number 20 for reissel
iglesias and the halos win a pitching
and defense night
just their third win of the year scoring
three runs or fewer angels take the
opener in minneapolis tonight beat the
twins by the final of three to two